Just a come and meet the family.
Please don't make me meet your family.
How did you meet Joey? How'd
you meet Joey Diaz? Uh,
I think Heidi set that up.
You'd never met him before?
He didn't show us via
Heidi. Via you. Ah, yeah,
I knew who he was and um,
he's a really lovable guy. Uh,
as soon as I met him,
I liked him just by seeing them online.
But when I met on my route, there's
nothing not to like, he's so honest.
He's full, full exposure.
Like who, who he is.
You get it in 60 seconds.
But I think it's why people like him
because there's no bs and like, you know,
there's the good,
the bad of anybody.
He lets you know who he is in the first
five minutes and you can take or leave
it,
but there's no ambiguity.
And I really like being around that
because you can be yourself because he has
shown enough being himself,
he's not holding back.
That's a really good way of looking at it.
You can be yourself because he
is being himself. Totally. And,
and he's not going to judge you on that.
He's going to give you the free,
and he's going to be himself,
but give you also the freedom to be
yourself unlimited. Yeah, I mean, it was,
we spoke for a while on his podcast,
had a great time,
and he's one of those guys, if he
called me at three in the morning, Hey,
I'm in trouble. I'm in San
Diego. I'm like, hold on, give
me three hours. I mean, I,
I'll help you and come and
meet the family. I please
send it to send a card.